[Musique]
le moment où est né le projet la flamme
c'est à 4 5 ans en fait j'avais vu le
projet original s'appelait burning love
qui s'est passé sur canal et j'avais
pété un câble alors burning love
c'est une fausse téléréalité c'est une
parodie du bachelor alors aux etats-unis
le bachelor c'est vraiment une
institution très très fort là c'était
vraiment une série parodique de a à z
très longue sur trois saisons jouées par
des acteurs de comédie qui sont
exceptionnelles des ken marino des ben
stiller et chez world c'est quoi ce
délire et on s'est dit tiens est ce que
ça vaut le coup de faire un remake une
adaptation de cette série là dont on
était tous très fans déjà
ça a pris un peu de temps pour avoir les
droits pour avoir tout ça mais c'est
vrai qu'on s'était dit bah ouais c'est
sûr qu'il ya quelque chose là qu'ils
peuvent vraiment assez décalé
correspondre aussi à l'humour de
jonathan et jérémy ce prochain billet je
le donne
on
alexandre alexandre accepté ce biais
j'ai pas fini en direction de mon coeur
je t'aime marque pour l'instant c'est
trop tôt je pense qu'on connaît et c'est
par ici prend pour l'instant à plus tard
alors lilas c'est la première et qui
j'en ai parlé de ce projet la première à
qui je n'ai pas toujours fait confiance
et qui m'a dit oui mais sans hésitation
je le fais je vais pas de pression nous
a raconté ya deux ans chez les là j'ai
un projet voilà c'est exister aux états
unis moi je veux ramener en france
s'appelle comme ci comme ça c'est
parodier comme si et c'est d'ailleurs tu
auras on rentre dedans et j'étais trop
contente
j'avais trop peur même qu'ils ne me dira
imagine finalement ils ne proposent pas
ont préparé un film ensemble à l'époque
et de kim n'avait pas aller il était
vraiment mais ultra séduit par le truc
et il voyait déjà comment le décalé
comme on le fait à sa façon et tout ça
c'est une barrière des dans cette
émission je trouvais que c'était
évidemment une très bonne idée et je
trouvais même si je dois être honnête
que que l'idée que ce soit lui qui s'en
emparent me semble être la meilleure qui
soit il a une intelligence dans l'humour
il a une finesse je n'ai jamais vu ça
c'est à dire qu'il ya des journées
entières où je le regardais que je me
dis je n'ai jamais vu ça et j'ai été
voir canal+ chez voilà j'ai ce projet là
j'essaie fille là qu'est ce qu'on fait
et ils n'ont pas attendu cinq sont loin
de me dire on y va
[Musique]
je pense pour les actrices la base y
avait un vrai qui favret des fils de fer
puis surtout bon ben voilà c'est drôle
il m'a fait lire les premières versions
des trois premiers épisodes et j'ai dit
ok c'est un délire je vois pas qui
comment et où mais franchement j'ai
complètement barré étrangement le
scénario m'a fait beaucoup beaucoup rire
moi j'aime beaucoup et c'est très con ce
réveillon est un chemin sûr très premier
degré 1
[Musique]
je me suis pas dit c'est génial que j'en
sois je me suis dit ah c'est génial que
ça existe même si je attendre l'avait
fait dire par amitié j'aurais été ravi
de lire ça je me suis vraiment vraiment
marre evra je me disais c'est pas parce
que moi ça me fait hurler de rire
c'est très drôle donc ça fait rire tout
le monde mais quand même pour rentrer
dans l'univers est ce que j'ai ce qu'il
faut à ma réaction a été de dire à
jonathan mais pourquoi je les joue pas
tout
j'aimerais trop ferrell un nom
finalement j'ai moins le trail en orange
enfin j'avais de l'amour et de
l'empathie pour tous les personnages en
fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on tourne les premiers
essais filmés de la flamme
là vous avez justement bas qu'au
réalisateur jeremy à lembeye de velours
n'a géraldine on à léonie simaga et on a
eu ces fâcheux dit cette femme je te
l'offre parking car pour moi tu es celle
alors
j'ai rempli tous plus calme wade à voir
la beauté la féminité l'humour et de
très belles mais est-ce que tu acceptes
de passage avec m
mais bien sûr quand j'ai lu le scénario
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment génial très
singulier on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
ça en france c'est très américanisée
comme univers c'est super grave c'est
bon t'es beau frère et le père belge de
dieu jonathan et jérémy cd machine
arrière
il joue avec les codes ils sont pas du
tout politiquement correct c'est
vraiment drôle
vraiment je ne jouerai pas dedans je
serai la première à regarder la flore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
ce qu'ils ont fait avec la flamme
ils ont rendu la série encore plus sous
acide presse qu'il ya un truc de
bachelor sous acide qui leur correspond
bien je trouve c'est toujours un univers
qui n'est pas complètement la réalité
c'est les personnages qui pourrait qu'on
pourrait presque croisé dans la vraie
vie mais qui n'existe pas et il ya le
fait de s'autoriser des séquences qui
d'absurdité complètement jouissive
[Musique]
si ça nous fait rire sera centrale dans
même si c'est absurde chelou c'est un
combat de fond on a fait ça passera
jamais apparaît des trucs vraiment
gratuit une noire j'ai jamais fait une
noix une femme de couleur de couleur
noire oui non fait
en fait le terme oui ces femmes de
couleur ah d'accord mais comme il ya
plusieurs couleurs je n'en suis dit que
c'est bien si j'ai été clair là dessus
même si c'est un peu parfois que les
chais de dire ça c'est un peu un humour
aussi à l'américaine c'est à dire que
toutes leurs références sont beaucoup
lié à ça on était fan tous les deux une
série qui s'appelle arrested development
et qui est vraiment le truc qu'on s'est
dit plus tard jason bateman will arnett
mais que ça va tout cet toute cette
bande là du d'un pato paul figues
d'absurde
en fait d' absurde et en même temps mais
revient degré très touchant avec des
vrais personnages et hilarant
[Musique]
on a abordé la flamme comme une fausse
téléréalité mais au final nous ce qu'on
a apporté c'est un fils de série on
garde fictionnel où on a essayé de faire
des fils rouges qui tiennent jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'au final on avait beaucoup
plus de matière à devoir créer parce que
c'est vrai que la série jeunesse les des
séries de ces des épisodes de 13 minutes
et nous aider on faisait des 26 donc on
a dû écrire plus de matière et en fait
on écrit deux épisodes en plus on a on a
changé beaucoup de cet add on a gardé
principalement les personnages parce
qu'ils étaient là leurs caractéristiques
tito et c'est vrai pour primer
développement il ya mis notre patte et
on a dérobé les situations mais on a
créé presque une histoire qui avait
vraiment pas dans la dans la dans la
série originale surtout sur personnage
principal de marque je vois jouer par
jonathan est bon c'est vraiment marrer à
écrire ce à quoi la honte est pour la
première fois des décors vraiment
principaux qui est le confessionnal de
la maison du bachelor pour nous la dea a
été très très très très importante
voulais que ça ressemble maximum au
bachelor américain dans l'imagerie dans
l'as des as dans tout dans les costumes
en fait abandonner quand joyce et il a
mis le costume qui s'est assis dans le
fauteuil du confessionnal et qu'on a vu
au combo trouvera fait c'est un bachelor
c'est bien écoutez franchement je suis
là pour le coup c'est la première fois
que qu'on va dire que je vais être un
peu beau à l'écran c'est important ce
que mon personnage est tellement con
[Musique]